[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the demo for mr white um alexian
this looks like a hyper-realistic
version of lunky like when you agree
it's kind of a little bit too much your
sleep paralysis demon i agree anyway
yeah this is this is mr white um let's
just see what it practice mr white is
sleeping he won't chase you mr white is
walking slowly and running very slowly
mr white is walking and running in his
regular speed mr white is walking and
running really fast mr white has removed
all clauses of bedford
do you guys want me to try impossible i
i think i think i should try impossible
i think i should kick it off with a
little impossible
let's see what it's all about after
jesus after kidnapping you mr white
dropped you in one of his sleeping rooms
you need to get in the red room
find all of these five elements and put
them on magic wall to open it so get a
green key a saw blade a red key
some kind of bracelet or a watch and a
blue key
kill mr red to get the red key
take the tool you find behind the wall
to destroy the exit door and escape mr
white's house
well i'm probably gonna die
um oh god
how do i turn
hello
how do i
how do i turn my
what
my mouse doesn't seem to be
what i can't turn
my my mouse no turn i'm pressing all the
buttons
in no turn i'm i'm using the arrow keys
the arrow keys go left and right it all
straights q and e doesn't do it man i
think i'm
i think i'm borked oh mouse sensitivity
zero
that's probably the problem let's try
that
oh there we go i see
that's strange here we go
this is on impossible mode
i don't really know what to make of
impossible
i don't really know what to make of
impossible mode
[Music]
that's probably not good
[Music]
none of this is probably very good
hey that's handy isn't that one of the
things that i needed
[Music]
okay
[Music]
anything in here toilet paper plenty of
tp
i just have a saw blade for some reason
can i kill mr red with this
is that what i'm doing here
oh i thought that was him
[Music]
all right
well so far this doesn't seem too
impossible
[Music]
all right well um
well that's that then try one more time
and then i'll drop the difficulty down
because this is on impossible and i'm
pretty sure that impossible is actually
impossible
hey look at that i got a whatever that
is
oh
oh god damn it all right well
i've got this
cue to drop i don't know what to do
though so i'm gonna just leave him there
for the moment
i don't know what the music is all about
okay
oh i hear footsteps i hear pitter patter
i hear pitter patter
i hear pitter patter pittering and
patterning
what's happening where am i oh
pitter-patter pitter-patter
there's pitter and then there's patter
oh my god
nothing
a whole lot of nothing
don't know why i'm here what is it what
are you
a big red dildo
can i hop up on this no
am i outside is this supposed to be
suggestive oh
damn i should have carried one of those
things
oops all right let's see if i can get
back and get it
i don't know if that's gonna happen
hi
okay they're over here somewhere
aha oh damn it
nothing
oh come on
really
[Music]
[ __ ] oh
oh
okay
grabbing this i'm gonna take this over
there where i saw that thing and i'm
definitely gonna die 100 guaranteed
going to die
place your bets now for how dead i am
which is extremely
whoa what
where am i
where am i
i can't see anything
oh
no no hey what are you doing yeah
all right i don't think it's impossible
on impossible
weirdly enough
i know that's a bold claim for me to
make
but i'm thinking
that it's not actually impossible
because if it were impossible then i
don't think i would have lived that long
okay
you feeling me you understanding me you
get what i'm saying here i don't know
where the green door is but i got i'm
gathering
that
red mr red is downstairs the whole time
so what i need to do is i need to find a
way to kill mr red
lukey
oh my god
all right
trying that again
that you i
no i didn't hear no pitter no patter
there's no pitter
no patter
definitely no pitter no pattern
zero pitter
minimal patter okay that's a blue key i
remember there being a blue door
i do believe it was over here somewhere
but i am a dead man
i am a dead i heard better batter better
powder
ah i heard bitter batter bitter and
better
pluto okay cool blue
where where is this where am i was where
why why why did i go in this room
there's nothing in here why would
why would you have a blue door that goes
into a blue room that doesn't have
anything in it
why would you do that to me maybe it's
just a way that i can
do i need the blue okay so it's unlocked
now
is that forever that it's unlocked
because that's good maybe i could go in
there to get away from
the dude
okay this is back outside i don't think
that there's anything here
to get other than this
downstairs area i'm thinking that you
probably could use the saw blade
to kill
mr red
and that's why that's there
and i think mr white must be relegated
to the exit area which i am looking at
right now
[Music]
i'm probably fine
it's all good
so good he ain't here
he ain't here green door okay
interesting i thought i saw i thought i
felt i feel something i'm feeling it
i'm feeling the thing need the red key
there okay that's not there this isn't
here that's not there that's a red door
i hear a bitter batter i hear pitter
patter i hear pitter and patter
pittering and powder i'm dead
i'm a dead man
okay i'm fine
oh no all's good here
these doors are open which is
interesting
okay
i'm fine boy i wish i had a flashlight
which i do not
okay well it's a whole lot of nothing
down here
so what am i supposed to do
because i need a red key for that this
door doesn't open
this is just a table i found next to
nothing here
i don't even think i found the saw blade
on this playthrough
oh my god oh my god
that guy just comes out of nowhere and
man when he gets you he starts sucking
right away
that guy that guy starts with the suck
that guy gives no quarter
all right let's try that once more
clearly this is the way that it's meant
to be played on impossible
because how else would you get good
the answer is that you would not
all right
nothing
it's a whole lot of nothing
it's just a big nothing
i'm gonna get nothing again
god i wish i could see
what do you mean you see me
i'll kill your ass i
okay you see me that's great good for
you man
well you better not you better stop
looking close your eyes i'm naked
i'm a dead man i'm a dead man
tell me kelly come on count i want you
to do it oh is it weird if you i want
you to
[Music]
i guess i'm fine all right face me
face me
oh my god
oh my god
oh all right
all right
iced tea
you yeah that's about what it is he just
wants to give me a nice refreshing glass
i i think that they should have been
braver and made this always be
impossible because it seems to be like
the way to actually get the scares out
of it i doubt it would be anywhere near
as
threatening if it was anything less
so honestly good for it
i heard the bitter batter
all right maybe i should
maybe i should try this um okay let me
keep him
running walking really fast but he has
not removed the closets in the bed i'm
gonna try it on hard you can mock me all
you want you can like
say whatever you want about me and my
skill level i'm doing this for your sake
i'm worried that you're gonna be too
scared i'm worried that you don't have
enough pairs of underwear to live
through this game okay that's what i'm
i'm doing this for you all right let's
try this again
all right kill mr red to get the red key
of course
why not
all right
ah bed
oh
that's very it's brighter
i can see
closet
handy
wow look at this
ha ha sick
all right so this should give me a
fighting chance maybe
looky perfect
well not perfect i don't really know if
there's any benefit to it
i hear that i hear that
outplayed outplayed [ __ ] outplayed
[Laughter]
let me go and open the blue door
maybe there was something in here but
probably not that's a big bed
hey mr white you want to join me in the
uh
large bed
okay so saw blade i'm guessing i need
that
oh my god
i had everything for me right then and
there i had everything in the palm of my
hand and i fumbled it
i really fumbled it
everything was there for me and i
fumbled it i'm not gonna lie uh
that was my bad
that was that was my bad
that was my bad
idiot
fool
[Music]
nerd
damn he quick he's really quick
okay
gunning it
gunning it
skill skill all skill skill skill skill
all skill skill
skill skill skill skill
all skill skill all day skill skill 100
skill
skill
skill
skill
skill 100 skill
delete elite skill
top tier top tier skill
top to your skill skill
100 skill
where's the closet where's the closet
get me in the closet give me a closet
where's the closet damn it
[Music]
skill
okay
green key there
okay this is downstairs there might be
some goodies down here
is he down here is he down here
uh he's down here skill skill skills oh
i've got a closet oh okay oh
uh turns out i still had room to grow my
skill can still improve and so i will
not allow my
uh skill to go wasted um
every op every failure is an opportunity
to grow uh and i'm going to take this as
such as that as the thing that that is
i'll leave that right there for now
now watch as um
as i unleash my ultimate move
which is probably
pissing myself or something like that
i would like to
just play this normally uh without
incident i would like to have a good
time
just a nice little adventure you know
and um
not die
immediately i would like to uh
have a chance i would like to uh
exist for a little bit i would like to
be able to discover
who i am and what i'm doing in this
world
oh this is how i die
really
[Music]
i'm running i'm running i'm running very
fast i wish i was running faster i'm not
running fast enough i'm not running
nearly fast enough where am i where am i
uh uh
oh [ __ ] oh damn it i feel well do you
but oh boy
oh no i had my chance
all right skill engaged it's fine it's
fine everybody shush i'm concentrating
everyone be quiet especially you lexie
and you be quiet elixir and be quiet
everyone
tells you to be quiet right now he's
judging me harshly and i can't i can't
handle that i won't handle it i refuse
to handle it okay blue key i love blue
key blue key's my favorite key
i'm gonna go downstairs real quick why i
don't know
why wouldn't i
shut up
god this is a problem
no it's not
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right good skill
excellent skill
best skill actually
none of that there was nothing down
there that was a completely useless
adventure
that doesn't sound good
oh that sounds bad
whoop
the fool
the fool has underestimated
undressed me
he's undressed me
once again believing himself not
[Music]
good enough
me not good enough he underestimated me
by believing that i was not good enough
but he
is the fool
oh well there's this thing okay so i
haven't found the saw blade on this
particular death yet but i'm going to go
ahead and unlock this so i can pop that
there
and then i can i believe it's got to be
the saw blade right it has to
did i i
i think i saw a swinging white arm there
pretty sure i saw pretty sorry that was
a pasty white arm i'm just gonna assume
that i saw a pasty white arm there
that's a problem
i'm getting good all right so i need to
find the saw blade
or the green key
or my balls i dropped them somewhere on
the sprint away i think there might have
been one more
why is he down here why
oh there's the saw blade
why would he be down there
did he just go sprinting up i think he
did
he's am i right
i'm fine
i'm fine
i'm fine skill skill represents skill oh
you actually do go faster if you strafe
all right this is the ultimate test
let's see what happens die die die
die
die
okay why would they put a closet here if
maybe this whoa
skill
skill skill skill so if you strafe at
the same time you do go a little bit
faster
whoa there you are
what
wario holy [ __ ]
skill skill skill
skill oh
really
well how do i kill him then
so how do i kill him i'm guessing i stab
him
should i try to stab him
i think i should try to stab him i'm
pretty sure that i trish i should try to
stab them i don't know how to use the
saw blade though
so i i don't really know what to do
about it
[Music]
you get stabbed and get stabbed
take my saw blade [ __ ]
take my saw blade look at this
gremlin there you are there you are
yeah there i am
[Music]
i don't know how to stab him i don't
really know how to play this game
there's really not a lot of answered
questions here maybe i got to get mr
white to kill mr red maybe that's what i
got to do hey uh mr red can you come
over here for a second
whoa
that was a little closer yeah here i am
indeed
so why don't you come up here
we're gonna have a little adventure
we're gonna do a pow wow
and uh
i hear two pitter patters well if i drop
it it just drops it's not like he kills
him
oh y'all i don't know
i'm at a loss
all right i'm gonna try
to drop it in front of him and maybe
that'll kill him somehow whoa
take this ha there you are oh it did
wait what the hell
no it didn't
maybe it would have maybe it would have
happened if i had been holding it and
then i charged at him i don't know it's
not really clear what i'm supposed to do
okay i got the saw blade but i don't
have the way to open that thing again
maybe it was just like i needed to hold
it i don't know
yeah red key i know he has the red key
whoa hey bud
he has the red key left click the saw
blade on him yeah that would make sense
wouldn't it but
yeah i need to okay i got the elements
that i need to be able to do that
okay let me tuck this down there for a
second
okay
grab this
i'm pretty sure
let me grab that saw blade so i don't
have to come back in here
i'm just gonna try this if this doesn't
work then i don't know what the hell i'm
supposed to do
okay
open
grab
drop down and i'm gonna click the [ __ ]
out of you i'm clicking the [ __ ] out of
you come here [ __ ] well i'm double
clicking i'm triple clicking yo i'll
take this take this take that take one
of these
is there something i've missed in the
instructions
let's do medium okay uh
the finals haven't put them on
magic wall to open
kill mr red to get the red key
i don't know
i don't know man
saw blade maybe this isn't a saw blade
well i mean it looks like a saw blade
but it doesn't function like a saw blade
for sure
oh no here's this thing
i don't know how you kill him
i don't know what you're supposed to do
to kill him
i really don't know
there's the green key okay let me open
the green key door
see where that is
all right val
you calm down there
all right i'm in the green there's
nothing in the it's just another hidey
hole
all right sure whatever you say buddy
whatever you say
i dropped the saw blade somewhere i just
don't remember where maybe i need to use
this thing on them maybe i shake this
shimmy shammy at him
[Music]
what
what
what does that do
wait a minute
[Music]
there were these things on the wall
weren't there
no there you are oh god what did i just
what did i just do what did i do
wait
oh
hold on hold the phone
hold your balls i don't know hold
something it either like jutted
something out from the wall or close
something on him and that would kill him
right am i right yes i am
shut up no one can disagree
how right i am i am right
i am 1000 right
no one has ever been more correct
than i am in this moment
yeah you do yeah you do yeah you do no
you don't
yeah hold your balls or hold your tits
or whatever i don't care just hold
something
because i'm about to throw down
mr red is about to get smooshed
mr red is about to become mr dead
man this is why people watch me my humor
my incredible humor
my outstanding levels of humor
so what did i
weird okay i didn't even notice that
before
because i didn't click it right
okay
so mr red
if that is your real name
i want you to see something come here
oh that's what it is
he's dead
are you dead oh my god he's dead really
anticlimactic but man he is dead
i have the red key now
life is good
[Music]
i see i open the red door
ah-ha
the blue key is here of all places all
right well i don't even well i might
need to
uh let me go
where'd that thing go i dropped it over
here okay well this is uh
he's dead
[Music]
anyway skill all right
so you there
got that there you put that there cool
i'm gonna bring this just in case i need
it but i don't think i'll need it
not now not now [ __ ] not no
all right anyway
maybe i could kill mr white in the
smooshy
is that possible
whoa my god mr red white whatever your
name is
i think he went to the right there i
think he did i heard that yeah
confirmed confirmed confirmed 100
confirmed
okay so now i just need to hunt down all
the other items that i did not find
which should be so easy
so so easy
aha there's a saw blade let me open up
this room here um i already put that in
the thing
okay saw blade and then
green key is the only thing that i need
left i can actually get to that place
quicker
by going down this way
hey dude never mind i'm gonna go this
way now
never mind okay
and so long as i do not [ __ ] it up from
this moment forward i am going to be
okay
[Music]
okay so i just need the green key maybe
it's down here somewhere
i didn't really look too closely i don't
think i did anyway
[Music]
baby
baby
baba boy
wow okay
okay
i do not trust this to kill you i do not
i do not trust that to kill him i'm not
gonna try it i'm not gonna try it after
all this i don't think that's for
killing him
the unfortunate thing is i can't really
hear
him anymore
i'm the best
more coming
that's it oh
all right
well
i'd call that pretty good
i'd say that was a success i really
earned that one
uh
i'm the best mr white can suck it mr red
is dead
it doesn't do it i'm not gonna do
impossible i'm not gonna do that
[Music]